probably
the player that I didn't get on with he
didn't get on with me and I didn't get
on with him was Craig Bellamy and I
turned around him and I said you've
changed since she played for England
next year it's in the newspaper no
really yeah and you're thinking how sad
is that I'm really good at it that I've
made a mistake and Vincent company put
his arm around he says Mark we'll all
make mistakes don't worry and when he
referred United it would just keep
coming at you one by one the try and get
the next decision push you push you push
in you know real Ferdinand was a master
of it he would come in then Gary Neville
would come in and Nikki butt would come
in right Kim would come in they were
just systematically coming at you
[Music]
welcome to sport Bible stories I'm Rory
Jennings and I'm mad Mirza there and
today we welcome the one and only Mark
clattenberg onto the podcast thank you
so much
thank you thank you so much for joining
us Mark no problem really appreciate it
no it's great to have you and um of
course we've got to start uh you left
the Premier League in 2017. uh what was
your reason behind you because uh even I
was trying to tell you Peerless you know
he said he's begging you to stay um
what was the decision why did you make
that decision you know what it's
I was officiating the best league in the
world the Premier League is the best
league in the world for excitement so if
I'm going for football and reasons then
I've made the wrong decision however
you not got a big future in referee
refereeing can be you can end your
career the next week bad performances
you can lose your contract in the
Premier League you can stop refereeing
matches abroad and you wait for in FIFA
so you've got a short lifespan so I've
got a look after my family so I had an
opportunity to go to Saudi Arabia for a
lot more money it gives us a new
challenge because I just refereed many
big matches around the world and I've
done every Premier League game so
therefore I needed a new challenge Saudi
Arabia give us that challenge but
probably like Cristiano Ronaldo will
probably say now except he'll be talking
a bit more about more money
but in general it's a challenge and I
took that challenge so to leave the
Premier League it was sad because you
had characters like Tony pulis you know
Neil Warnick these type of managers were
great Banner to have around and you know
they appreciated good referees who used
to have Banda back and you know was a
strange move at first going from Saudi
Arabia to Saudi Arabia from from England
but after a few months it was soon
forgotten and you know the abuse
the abuse of social media for example
you know seemed to drop it only seemed
to increase when covert happened because
it started re-watching rewinding All of
Me Bad performances from many years ago
because I had no live matches so that
started again the abuse do you think you
could still do a job in the Premier
League now what not what you see the
size
what about in terms of just just not in
terms of Fitness in terms of the
officiating no I think I think if I'm
honest you think you can do it but
mentally I haven't got that no that came
to me when I went to China so I left
Saudi after two years went to China and
for the first three four months I was
nowhere near to the levels because I
dropped so much from the Premier League
to Saudi because the intensity of Saudi
football and I wasn't referring regular
I seemed to drop Fitness levels I wasn't
seeing the decisions the same as I was
when I was in the Premier League so
therefore I'm not sure I could do it a
job now and I think the referees now are
probably in a better State psychological
fitness-wise would probably take us at
least a year now on what 47. you know
I'm I'm too old now I don't say that
mate
um and culturally as well obviously
China Saudi Arabia very different
culturally to England let's say was that
a big shock to you was that all right I
love that I love challenges I loved you
know the different cultures Arab
cultures is completely different and you
know for example you would be in Saudi
Arabia and they would have a big match
Halal NASA as the two big clubs and it
would go on for hours that they would
change the match two days before the
game they're going to change the match
from a Sunday to a Monday to a Saturday
to a Sunday and this is like a big match
and this never happened in England the
game was kicking off exactly what the
stated unless TV changed but they
weren't well known there were no well in
advance but in Saudi Arabia they would
just make random decisions and sometimes
that would impact on my
you know appointments as well because I
was bringing foreign referees in so they
were coming in with flights and I must
having to rearrange stuff and you know
the sports Minister for Saudi always
wanted foreign referees this was not my
decision I wanted to develop the local
referees but you know the the sports
Minister wanted then hand Saudi football
by bringing the best referees in the
world best players in which is what
they're doing now so you know it was
you know culturally it's completely
different and then China is another
experience because I couldn't speak to
me family till the afternoon because of
the time differences the food was a
disaster for me yeah because
is it is it is an athlete you want to
you want to eat well so I would be in a
hotel before a game say for example
Guangzhou and you can't get like normal
European food and you know you you I
used to meet the referees sometimes for
lunch and they'll be in like ducks feet
and duck speaking Duck's tongue and I'm
like how can you eat that before again
that was because we're European we want
pasta we want stuff that'll give us the
carbs but in China I wasn't getting the
car I was losing so much weight and I
was fatiguing during matches so it was a
complete you know different culture
shock but it had been pre-covered so the
stadiums were full it was a great
atmosphere I love my time in China I
would I would have went back but covered
ended it you know when you talk about
these experiences they sound incredible
but do you just miss the rigors of the
Premier League
not now not now and I think Tony pulis
probably would say the same I think once
you're out you see a different world I
think when you're in you're in this
bubble you know you the stresses the
media the the social media the abuse
that used to take before and after
matches and I remember like for example
me I think the second last match was at
West Brom I think you know Mike Riley
didn't like us because I refereed West
Brom twice and fourth official once in
the last three games of the Premier
League so and nothing against West Brom
but I had to stand next to Tony pulis to
get abused because he was one of the
most difficult difficult managers but
you know I remember and I referred the
game and I'd made three decisions
against West Brom three big decisions
and all three were correct and he the
abuse I took after the match the
following week I went back to the same
stadium nobody said a word nobody
apologized nobody said I was right
do you mean do you mean from The
Terraces yeah Terraces the court and
staff because they think they've been
wrong till let's see it on TV that they
haven't been wrong then reality is
different and I probably people would
say VR stopped a little bit of this
because you'd get the chance to see it
again but I was adamant what I'd seen on
my two eyes was was correct so I called
the decision and you know thank God in
that game it was three raid decisions
he's supportive of VAR generally
yes or no gun for example
the first time ever at Old Trafford I
was the referee who didn't allow Paulo
mendez's Wonder strike from the halfway
line
yeah so Roy Carroll scooped it behind
the line and people said to me how did
he not say it are you crazy you stand on
the halfway Airline
and you know people don't really have
the reality you know there's no way I
can say it it's a linesman's role as
well though isn't it yeah but when you
see a shot coming in from 50 yards how
can an assistant referee run down the
touch line and be 100 in line with a
goal line to be 100 because you might
have a feeling you can't go on feeling
you can't turn around and say I think
it's a goal you've got to be 100 sure to
call him yeah I remember this match just
a little funny story and I remember that
it was my very first time at all travel
of course it's got stresses and it was
little little finish nil should have
been one nil at Tottenham with his goal
and um as I was coming off the sky
Steadicam came direct to me and I
thought oh my God have you the [__] up
our man
hahaha
[Laughter]
so so using that goal as soon as you
start talking about Pedro Mendes you
immediately would suggest that you're in
favor of VAR but you did say yes or no
yeah yeah of course there's I think it's
spoiled again I think you know the
emotion side of it I think I I believe
the World Cup got better because of this
semi-automated however it caused
confusion in the very first Opening
match with this semi-automated offsides
I think
we want to see gold scored and we'll be
able to celebrate and I think maybe in
five years time with VR evolving even
more and more and more and the level of
VR intervention should be less and let
the referees referee like we used to
and only rely on it when it's needed
then I think it could be in a better
shape but at the moment
every week they're arguing pundits are
arguing people are arguing every day why
is a VA are not interfered is that a
foul why is that not given there's just
so many opinions and at the end of the
day
referees had opinions I used to go to
every Fortnight to a meeting with the
referees and we used to argue so what
chance is everybody else got if we're
arguing what's a foul what's not because
at the end of the day it's what you say
out your two eyes how much intention
there is how much you know contact there
was and contact football's a contact
sport and what you sometimes say you go
why is that not a penalty and we're like
there's not enough contact but people
will say it's still a foul and then
you've got the argument again so
it's not like cricket and Tennis where
it's factual yeah it's a little
subjective uh password also with VAR as
well um I I'm a big believer of like I
think the technology is great but it's
the people that are using it sometimes
get things wrong so would you would you
be up for having like a let's say an
x-pro in there that understands the game
or do you think that'll be actually into
the technology no I think it'll be a big
thing going forward I think Howard
Webb's openly said from the day he took
the job from Mike Riley recently in the
last months is that he wants ex-players
refereeing and he wants X player's
refereeing which means with the training
as a referee you'll be able to to act as
a VR because you need that experience in
the middle as a referee to be able to
act as a VR you can't just
you know train somebody from the street
to Bay of AR they've got to know and
feel what's going on and you know I
believe ex-players is the way forward I
think it will happen more but uh from
one of my experiences I I remember
working with Stevie Baines who was an
ex-professional and he was fast tracked
in as a referee and um I was an
assistant referee from and as I was
warming up as we used to warm up before
the game
I'm looking for Stevie Baines I couldn't
find him and I'm thinking where is he
and there he was in the corner putting
balls into the goalkeeper he still
thought he was a player
I forgot that he was a referee and you
know they've got to make that transition
you know what what players expect and
it's now different because for example a
player might not see that as a bad foul
but as referees under our guidance and
criteria that will follow we'll think
it's a bad challenge so you've got to
find that medium ground of what's
expected in football totally so you've
refereed some of the biggest occasions
that there are in football including the
sidemen match recently what a game one
of the best games most entertaining
games I've ever referred really how did
it come about that you ref that yeah me
Agent
no it was you know I was approached to
referee it and I didn't know this is how
bizarre and funny it was
I'm thinking who am I referee
I didn't know is it a culture you're
aware of then the the YouTuber no no my
daughter who's 11. I'm saying I'm
refereeing this game and my daughter
11's gone
can you get his shirt can you get it can
you get his [__] I'm like who are they
yeah and then when you realize who these
people are I'm like wow they're like the
following Stars yeah a huge does but
what I was so impressed with okay I'd
referred one or two of them for soccer
raid
but the level of performance it was why
I'm saying it was one of the most
entertaining games it was 7-6 I think
yeah and some of the goals were on yeah
the log for the winner was incredible so
you know sometimes you get better games
with players who probably aren't
professional footballers and you know
the enjoyment I remember speed yeah yeah
you think it was about 500 yards offside
it's just scored side to side of God for
a bit of fun I'd give me yellow card for
taking his shirt off I should it's quite
ripped anyways
so yeah so as you had a laugh give him a
yellow card and then he started chasing
us around but it's so fast I think I I
must have ran 10 meters
should you send him off early do you
think there was a challenge it was a bit
Vinnie Jones
[Laughter]
you know when you've got a charity oh no
you know I think it was for the chair it
is and stuff out your referee is
slightly different because you know it's
about enjoyment one two about raising
money as long as you know we can we can
officiate and play in the right Spirits
you know it's not like refereeing in a
premier league where it's black and
white I think and charity matches the
most important thing is that they make
money and it goes to the right causes
I'm getting more entertainment as we saw
on the 76 score line yeah I loved it it
was unbelievable and have you kept in
touch with any of them and hit other
players oh no no I did I did not vote
was with uh it was a chunksy oh yeah
yeah I didn't advert with him recently
yeah
and if given the opportunity would you
referee another side man charity match
of course it may agent letters
no and of course it you know I enjoyed
it that much you know on it 26 000
assault the tickets immediately you know
I think there was millions of people
watching it on YouTube so you know it
has its it has its um you know it's
important points and you know if the ask
is again costs like soccer Aid every
year they keep asking us to do it
because you're a part of the show and
you know I'm now I'm a retired you know
I'm probably helping the game go and
enjoying it as much as we can would you
describe yourself as a star now would
you say that that's what I've never
there's one thing I've always learned
you're never a star in refereeing and
you're just a part of the game and you
know what what I learned over the years
is and football fans are very you know
they call they talk about the laws of
the game they talk about following rules
but at the end of the day it's like
policemen you've got a set of rules
you've got to manage the rules you've
got to interpreted the rules and at the
end of the day you're just a referee the
players are the stars but it's a top
referee you can hunt the game you can
play good advantages and keep the game
flowing and that's important for a top
referee to keep the game going because
you know people want to see action they
want to see goals and that's what sells
the Premier League product because it's
one of the most exciting
exciting leagues in the world you know
so Mark we're going to do some quick
fire questions with you now if that's
okay just to get to know you a little
bit better oh um we're gonna start with
who did you support when you were
growing up not Sunderland
Newcastle of course so the second
biggest Club in North East oh sorry
rories
oh love it I'll tell you why
we can talk about
Club who's in the Premier League who's
in but I remember a story how big you
know the clubs are and someone are a
huge club for example when they're in
League one 45 46 000 in amazing I
remember
it was when Newcastle win the
championship suddenly win the Premier
League Sunderland on a Tuesday night at
home we're playing Chelsea
42 000. the Stadium's 48. so 6 000
shorts
Newcastle the following night played
Sheffield Wednesday at home
52 000. that sums up
amazing uh favorite footballer growing
up
of course we it's different because I'm
always I'm always going to say Newcastle
I started off when my father took this
Chris waddle Peter Beardsley and then it
went through spells of David genola
you know Les Ferdinand them
fastino aspr remember the day when I was
in the Gallagher Inn when he scored
three against Barcelona and crispy said
all three up but it was then you had
Alan Shearer
and then when you start not being a fan
because I've gone through that cycle of
being a football fan of course I'm still
a football fan when I'm a referee but
then I remember as a referee going
through my early part of my career I
remember refereeing Luis Suarez playing
for hayax
against slovan bratislav and he scored
four I was gutted because he took the
match ball offers
but you saw talent and you could say his
talent then he had the chance and lucky
enough to to referee Messi and Ronaldo
and there's a big argument who's the
best player in the world it's not for me
because they're all different but you
had the chance to see world-class
players and I used to pinch myself
thinking hey I'm on the pitch with these
players and you know something that you
know I hope that even ex-players or
young players who don't make it in the
game should try refereeing because you
get the chance to be a part of something
amazing you know have you got a favorite
player now
I haven't really got you know I watched
I watch football a lot and you you see
what's amazing now
you're seeing different Superstars rise
like if you looked at the Moroccan team
in the world cup you saw some great
players coming out of that and you see
you know some American players I had
them a few years ago I was working for a
US Channel and I got the chance to watch
the US team a few names you think wow
they're good players and then you see
them now in Europe you see some in the
Premier League so everything's evolving
so much it's young man's gaming you know
I haven't really got one Superstar
um but what I love
and you know looking back at Newcastle
for example I love
players like Dan burn why what's a
player he he start he got released by
his favorite Club Newcastle he's gone
through
the the not the long leagues but you
know Darlington in the lower leagues and
then rebuilt his career with Brighton
and then he's come to Newcastle you can
just see how much it means to a player
like that a bit like Alan Shearer was
and when he came back to play for his
Club home club and you know it must be
amazing to do that yeah and in terms of
like obviously your favorite footballers
you know obviously you went into
refereeing did you have an iconic
favorite referee
[Music]
probably because I was from the
Northeast George Courtney he was he was
from the Northeast so he referred
International matches so you had not an
icon but you followed certain Styles so
what I used to do is when I was a young
referee I used to analyze referee Styles
so I used to look at them and think what
were they doing that I could do so I
tried to take pieces from everyone
um and in the end you start them all the
way you want to be and then you listen
to coaches you listen to people
what you know for example probably
people used to say I speak too much on
the pitch but that but some people say
that was a positive some people with
that say that it was a negative so you
do try and
follow certain things and try to to mold
yourself but in the end you're just you
and you've just got to be yourself you
know and who would you say is the best
referee now
there's a you know there's two at the
moment and Anthony Taylor for example
is going off to the club World Cup in uh
in Morocco I think it is and then you've
got Michael Oliver but for me Michael's
from my region in the Northeast and he's
probably more of a natural referee but
he just needs to you know probably come
out with Michelle more maybe he's
coached that way
um where we were allowed to speak to
players it doesn't seem to come across
that now and that's probably now the
modern day referee is not engaging with
the players as much as they used to and
where we used to be able to have some
really good band and that used to save
yellow cards for example do you think
that's in fear of potentially getting
repercussions of that so if they say
something you're getting reported in the
paper and it's transpar from there we've
got now there's so much lip reading so
yeah and I remember we had situations
where now we as a group
um some referees got accused of speaking
to players inappropriately and we as a
group used to say well good and if
that's what you want next time you swear
at us or you say something in it
probably will send you off so you can't
have it both ways you have no idea but
you've got to have a level of a level of
banner I remember
um referee in Everton Southampton and um
it was it was Christmas Christmas time
and Adam lallana absolutely voluminous
with abuse and I mean after the match
volley I should have sent him off I had
the right to send them off
but I try to use my management skills
and I turned around them and I said
you've changed since you played for
England
next year it's in the newspaper no
really yeah and you're thinking how sad
is that I technically should have sent
you off well within me rights but I use
my mind management skills and then they
used it against us so you can't have it
both ways and you know that probably
changed more and more now in the modern
game that you know players now would say
to you you can't speak to me like that
and that's okay then so you've got to
have that
find balance to what players used to do
years ago the banter there's no such
thing as banter anymore so that's an
example those Adam lallana there is an
example of somebody who obviously didn't
appreciate that I would assume that the
majority of players would rather have a
relationship of discourse where you can
have a conversation sort it out rather
than getting booked or sent off and
ended up with a three-match ban for a
silly comment 100 so most players though
must have been receptive today yeah a
lot of players were a lot of players
were and um you know what I used to find
funny because you know how bad I used to
be and when he had a foreign player used
to sign for a club
you know you knew what was going to
happen next the foreign player was going
to swear at you and you're like and then
he used to see when he swore yeah
because he couldn't speak English
and you look around and all these
teammates
certain words not the correct words so
he believes it's right the speaker
not you know if you took that personally
knowing what's happening in red cardamom
you know when it's a joke and it's a bit
of you've got to then react to that as a
referee anything oh okay then but you
know you've got to be a part of that
part I think Dennis wise did a lot of
that to Jen Franco Zola yeah I think I
think he sort of used to suggest that he
would say things that were completely
inappropriate people I think that's a
better it's a better way to have a
relationship with a ref I'm sure yeah
and you know we never went out with them
never had a beer with them you know this
is fact you know they're football
players you had a line of respect have
you seen them have you seen them on
holiday or you've seen them in different
places of course it would speak that's
the line you know but at the end of the
day the referees have a job to do one
week you're the best referee in the
world the next win you're the worst and
players feel the same they feel like
you've been hard don't know but one
thing I always learned as a referee is
of the trust yeah Place trusty and
gorgeous trusted you you are your
decisions were accepted but they weren't
accepted on The Terraces because if you
give a decision against their team it
doesn't matter if it's right or wrong
the abuse you used to take
and going away from football um what's
your biggest interest outside of
football what do you enjoy doing most uh
I play a bit of golf I don't think as
good as Tony pulis was do you think he
has more time and he could play off it
depends if I want to win a competition
or not
to keep cutting us because I keep
winning I normally play up about 14.
okay yeah not bad but I always have two
golf balls in my pocket
there's no referees
correct probably people would say not
going to the World Cup finaling
the 2018 to Russia I was on the short
list I would have went 100 because I was
the only English representative an
English referees would have 100 went to
the to the finals of Russia but you know
I took it up it took an opportunity and
I'm a firm believer and I had this
conversation with my family
should I do it I would have regretted if
I didn't do it
then if I had you know do you understand
so I had to do it to regret it and I
never regretted it
but if I had said no to Saudi Arabia and
went to the World Cup I probably would
have regretted that for the rest of my
life so I'm a firm believer what comes
to you take it
and then regret it then not accept it
and regretting it so
not going to Russia
was probably just because everybody used
to say to me oh you could referee the
final I probably wouldn't have referred
the final because of politics and and
everything else plus England did well
for the first time in a tournament
because I used to have to rely on
England being knocked out of the
tournament so when England was so bad
I'm like chi-ching
I remember recently I must have been
happening a lot for example in France
you know and you had the chance of the
final in um
England were playing Iceland so we're in
this Barn it was full of England fans
and I'm the only I'm the only English
fan jumping up and down at the end of
the game everybody's looking at us going
what the [__]
because they'd annoy you know yeah and
on the flip side of like regrets and
stuff what's your proudest moment so far
probably
walking out of the Champions League
final
to have me family in the stadium to to
walk out and
you know you push yourself you sacrifice
a lot your family sacrifice a lot
um because you're away a lot you're
training a lot
sometimes for example my family when I
used to come back from a match on a
Saturday they would disappear because
they knew what if I had a bad match I
was in a foul mood so they knew so I'm
giving them something back to enjoy in
in in in in Milan which was the
championship fight in 2016 and I
remember the only thing I remember
because I can't remember much in the
match but I remember before the gaming
we're in a tunnel and it was cork air on
one side from Madrid and then you've got
Ramos
for for real and they're both screaming
at us before the game come on we'll want
to get out and I'm like well I can't do
anything I'm waiting I'm waiting for
them to tell us to walk out it was um I
think with Alicia Keys was singing and
they were telling us to go and stopper
and I'm like
a little bit of a panic moment and
there's the ball on the plinth
and I'm thinking to myself don't drop
the door don't drop the ball and when I
got the ball off the plinth I was like
oh it's amazing Adam who do you think
has been the most influential person in
your career probably family it is a
collective because
without your family in the sacrifice you
used to put he I wouldn't have been the
person I was you know they
they used to go through emotions of you
know and I suppose that would be the
same for a player and a coach you win
you're happy you lose but in refereeing
you never win because even if
it's a draw one team still complains
about decisions and I think when I first
started I remember this
when we first started we only had
newspapers and I used to love the Sun
newspaper because it's the market
and I didn't want a seven I hear it at
sevens I loved sixes because I used to
turn the paper upside down so I had a
nine
but then then
everything changed after that you had
social media and the problem with that
is it becomes permanent and then your
family starts reading it and the abuse
used to take from people with so much
that you know your family getting you
know get infected but
know over the years you try and teach
them not to not to read it you know and
be strong and they got the rewards
because you know they've got the chance
they've got the FA Cup Final Champions
League final Euro final so they've had
the chance to to see some of the most
amazing games in the world and they've
had the chance to watch Newcastle of
course has anyone ever given you a piece
of advice that has really resonated with
you that you've held on to yeah but when
I started off refereeing just be
yourself don't be anybody else be
yourself and I grew up in a in a not a
difficult life but you know what not a
privileged life so you've come from
counselor steering parents didn't have
much money and my father died early and
so you had all these things to deal with
and it just made you stronger and you
know the advice you know be yourself I
didn't want to be somebody so when I
used to speak to players
players used to have that relationship
because I used to speak to the best
player in the world the same as a
Grassroots player I didn't have any
heirs and Graces you know you get what
you get with me and players like that
they could you know I didn't muddy
cuddle millionaire players I just threat
them exactly the same and you know that
they liked it and you know I could build
that relationship up so it was a good
bit of advice for me so Mark obviously
you've reffed some of the biggest
occasions that there are in the sport is
there an occasion is there a match that
really uh sticks with you for just being
a classic football football uh occasion
yeah
and not because of the the high but
there was there was big Stakes on it it
was um Spurs Chelsea Spurs Chelsea was
that one with what the tool Stanford
Bridge
of course so if if you really go into
the the understanding of the game you
know there's a way for you've got to
understand the importance in the
importance is Leicester city had the
chance to win the title
and it was quite a unique moment in the
Premier League because no other team had
ever changed the dominance of if if the
big of the big sides for example and
Leicester won The Verge and they knew
that
Tottenham had to get a result again
sorry was it Stanford bridge
and I knew the importance of this match
and what you can read you can read in
the media what's going on the players
from Chelsea who had a bad season
for their standards were playing
an enemy yeah totally so therefore
I knew the importance the banter on
between the players all Chelsea cared
about was stopping Tottenham in the
title
and it started from the first whistle
they were just kicking lumps and people
say to me
why did you do why did you not apply the
laws of the game why did you not do this
why did you not do that with VAR with
VAR my mummy might not have finished the
match
but the problem was you're in this
you're in this spectacle you're in this
whole environment and what fans don't
understand is they want the letter of
the law literally applied but you know
the importance of the match and how
difficult the match is going to be and
when you saw
what went on and how for example
Tottenham the players went chills
equalized two two and had realized that
the title was slipping away you could
just see the discipline Illustrated lost
it the young players that weren't in
this situation before they didn't know
how to react to it and as a referee I
could go in
and solve it by giving red cards but it
could have the other effect so I'm
trying to work out what's the best way
to manage the till the end of this match
and probably the one of the regrets in
that match was probably not sending off
any um Eric Dyer yeah but what I saw and
I didn't register it because there was
that much going on around I didn't
register that it was Eric Dyer and I
played an advantage because Chelsea had
the chance to go on and score
but hindsight would have been that was
the one I could have just went
enough's enough
red card and possibly had one red card
at the end of the game but there was
criticism
on my performance by the purist but
actually as a sporting event around the
world that would have been watched as
one of the most enthralling yeah
it's an iconic game and you know what
you're so right about the sort of
magnificence of that occasion because
I'm a Chelsea fan and the week before I
think the weekend before it was St
George's down I remember going down to
Bournemouth we played at Bournemouth and
I've never been in a in an away end like
this before but
we weren't focused at all on that game
yeah all we were singing is make sure
that you beat Tottenham next week that's
all we were singing for 90 minutes all
we care about is not today it's about
the fixture that's coming in three or
four days time here because all you
wanted to do was stop Tottenham winning
the tale totally that's I mean that was
I remember I remember because we played
Leicester last day of the season I
remember on the build up once Chelsea
season was a write-off I remember saying
to my mate Chelsea have two things to do
this season we need to beat Tottenham
and Luther Leicester
not that not that year certainly not
um but gosh that must have been such
because it went really bad post the
full-time whistle didn't it yeah because
he didn't got pushed over
there yeah that was Costa that was Costa
normally it's the other way around
for him not to react I couldn't believe
it yeah does it go on after the you know
after the game then so you've blown the
full-time whistle yeah Stanford Bridge
erupts Tottenham fans of a livid and
then it that wasn't the end usually that
would be the end of it because the
players had lost discipline everybody
had lost the discipline because in
Tottenham but Chelsea had stopped on
them basically Leicester won the title
so their dream you've got to understand
football players it was their dream to
win the title and all of a sudden from
2-0 half time they've drawn the game two
two yeah and now the chance to make
Leicester go on and win the title
mentally was a challenge yeah you know
so Tottenham had the best chance ever to
win the title and they've lost the
moment so not that I defend players but
I can understand players as frustration
and as we're going down the tunnel
because it's also a very tight tunnel at
Chelsea everybody's trying to squeeze
into one area probably there was some
push and shoving probably more than
people thought it was good that what you
see because everybody's just trying to
get down the tunnel and then I think
poor go sitting was on the floor and
then you know I think Danny Rose was in
tears was he yeah did does it continue
does your role as a ref so do you then
go into your referee quarters yeah did
anyone come and see you is it is there
like a post-mortem of the occasion
for example in the Premier League we
don't have a referee observer so the
referee observer doesn't come there's no
ex referee comes here it's an X player
so he'll come in and give you from a
player's perspective a coach's
perspective A team's perspective
um and you get marked accordingly I
wasn't bothered about me Mark you know
it was more that I I came out of a game
without as least controversy as possible
because people say to me the referee is
the one that you don't see but there's
times where
even if you don't give decisions you get
criticized because people said I should
add four red cards but if I'd give four
red guards I would have been killed for
damage in the game so it's a very fine
balance so you know
um I'm a I remember that night going
back to the hotel I couldn't sleep but
the next morning was brutal because the
match reports had had a complete was
just unreal you know when you're in a
game like that can you appreciate it
because it
the epicenter of who you are you're a
football fan you know you're on the
gallaghetti end as a kid in that are you
appreciating what's going on like when
Eden Hazard that day in front of the
Tottenham fans in the sheddon scored one
of the best goals I've ever seen with my
own eyes are you feeling that as a ref
right when that ball hits the back of
the net do you have a moment and go wow
or are you so focused on um sometimes
when you see screamers
brilliant and sometimes you go past the
player but then the player sometimes
come back to you somebody you know the
feeling's mutual when something happens
in a game and a player does something
brilliant wow oh wow what a great goal
but when you play a good Advantage
players will come past you and say a
great advantage
especially when they've scored so
you know players aren't as bad as people
make out a bit you know if they do
something go why shouldn't the referee
say wow I remember some great goals what
was the best one you've seen
um
I've seen quite a few
trying to think of one you know I
remember Matty Taylor scoring a screamer
for football I suppose that was on the
volley yes yeah and you think that was
unbelievable unbelievable wow
and I remember like jakiri playing in
the in the Euro when he scored against
um I think was Paul was Paul was it
Switzerland Portland yes
and he used to say I remember saying to
me because he played with a stalk and he
always scored screamers and I think he
scored a screamer for stock and I was
riffing and he came past us that game
and he said to me he says Mark you're my
lucky references right he says every
time ask or screamers
that's close
um and then what's the toughest game
you've ever uh referred in the Premier
League yeah
there's there's also tough mental games
you know I everything had importance you
know I remember in my very first season
going to Crystal Palace and he said well
sorry Charlton Crystal Palace and he
said why John
the stresses that in that game for
Crystal Palace because there was three
teams vying to go down it was Fulham
Palace and
um West Brom and I remember Brian Robson
was a coaching all afternoon you're on
the pitch and you're hearing different
sounds from the stadium you're hearing
cheers you're hearing come on for the
place to hurry up and all of this you
know
transfers on the field of play so you're
trying to referee games known that the
scores are important so you've got to
react to that so the stresses I remember
me first you think wow this is like
unique and then I remember doing
like when Liverpool could have won the
title The First Time under Brendan
Rodgers and I remember them I was a
referee when the Big Man City three
three two yeah and I remember Gerard
crying telling us to finish the match
because it meant so much to them the
following week he slipped and gave
Denver bar the chance and then I
referred them at Palace yeah the thrill
and I remember the players this is how
crazy it was they were winning three nil
Liverpool and the players are telling me
to hurry the goalkeeper from Crystal
Palace I've never heard this before
yeah yeah when you're winning three no
but they they realized they needed it I
think it was a mangle swing so they're
trying to score more goals and I'm
thinking Mom yeah this is crazy and then
it went three one three two three three
and it could have been four three at the
palace and the fair play to Brendan
Rodgers you know after that and I think
he knew each title was over but he
waited for his outside me address and
Dawn he had absolutely no complaints and
he you know what coaches used to make
excuses certain coaches didn't and he
was one of the gentlemen was there a
particular ground that you didn't like
referring in yeah
there's two there's two one Norwich
and it was because the A14 was brutal
so it wasn't Delia Smith
because you couldn't get a flight there
unless you went via Amsterdam and the
Premier League wouldn't give you that
privilege
I was like ding dong
what you don't understand is if you're
driving from the north if anybody lives
in the North of England and you're
driving to Norwich the first three hours
is okay
well the last hour is brutal because
it's single Road and when you when
you're on a single Road and you're
driving it's the other side
that you're worrying about so you want
to get the knowledge and then the worst
thing especially on a night March the
first hour of that journey is brutal
because Pitch Black
there's tractors on the road and all
sorts and you're like want to get home
so that was never one of my most
memorable stadiums and probably the
other one was Palace and um I'll tell
you a little story about Palace and
they'll probably hear this still in um
it's one of the most bizarre statistic
that I have and it it's just unique I
remember refereeing Palace in the
playoffs against Brighton the win 1-4
they get a chance so Mark Lamberg isn't
the problem you know and then the minute
they get into the Premier League nothing
went right I probably compounded one or
two situations made mistakes 100
but there's other times and I remember I
think they were they'd lost six Premier
League games when I was rapping
or they hadn't won and six and I
remember they were playing Aston Villa
Aston Villa Plum bottom just after New
Year Plum bottom and I'm thinking and
this is the moment the most win
you know statistics tell you the Crystal
Palace were a decent side
the lower bottom
Hennessy threw one in they got beat one
nil I'm thinking this is my life this is
supposed to seven I still get the blimp
I think it went at 12 or 30 and then the
cup they never won a game in a premier
league when I was rafting wow and then
we went to The Cup Final and didn't play
an advantage in the opening minutes
probably just because Wembley it's if
you know FA Cup Final it's like a player
you want to get on the ball I wanted to
blow me whistle and I probably should
have played sure I should have played an
advantage you don't know what's going to
happen the scored kind of Wickham scored
but everybody had stopped everybody
makes an excuse for it but it was one of
them where everything seemed to go wrong
for Palace but I remember the cup final
for example
I've never had this unique statistic I
go up one side
of man united to collect me metal I'm
getting booed as I come back down I'm
getting booed up Palace
I'll tell you what as a Brighton fan
that makes me really happy so hopefully
we can get you back into it really you
know get some more Palisades under your
belt um and then talking to clubs what
about players was there any players that
you had run-ins with or ones you thought
I've got him today and I don't want to
refer him I think one of the most pla I
think some referees say the same thing
so I'm not unique when I say this
probably
the player that I didn't get on with he
didn't get on with me and I didn't get
on with him was Craig Bellamy
and some of it's my fault
but I'll what what I loved and I wish
and I and I keep saying this uh to
Newcastle United they should have kept
them just signed them on a 20-year deal
because if he stayed at Newcastle I
wouldn't have had the chance to referee
him so therefore I wouldn't have crossed
paths yeah but the moment he left
Newcastle I started referring him and he
played for Man City and it was my fault
it was my own fault because he abused Us
in the first half I give him a yellow
card and going back to what how in the
modern day how things change I remember
half time to a coaching staff in Man
City saying how do you how do you put up
with this guy he's constantly abusing is
is this what he like on the in the
training ground that ended up in the
newspapers so that's what happened in
football so sometimes your best off not
speaking yeah
um and then I ended up sending them off
and when you watch it it was a penalty
and I caution for diving
he wouldn't forgive us and he was right
I was wrong you know and I probably got
sucked into his way of you know he was
not manipulative but he was hard work
and he was in your face he was in your
ear he was you know not controlling but
he was difficult and he probably I ended
up spending more time with him fighting
with him then I should have I should
have just left them would you admit that
to him though like would you say look
last game I made a mistake you know or
would you try and explain your decisions
to him to try and help maybe yeah he did
he grabbed me balls in the tunnel Man
City no there's a laugh it's a joke of
course
but you know probably me and him I've
I've been missed made many mistakes to
players
but they they've easily recovered from
it they move on from it you know Mark
I've made a mistake I remember Vincent
company for example I'd made a mistake
in the first half and I'm coming off
coming out of the second half and I'm
gutted I'm really good at it that I've
made a mistake and been some company put
his arm around he says Mark we'll all
make mistakes don't worry and you know
different levels yeah you know different
people different human beings yeah and
any other players spring to mind like
what about John Terry and he run into
that I like John yeah I mean John
was a gentleman I'm talking what I said
about advantages if you played did
something good he would compassion say
great great job you know so yeah that
side of him I never had any big Runnings
but I sent him off
and I set him off late on in his career
he was playing was West bomb Chelsea and
um when I sent him off he was sent off
the last man of denial and as I'm coming
back in the Midwest and with West Brom
they was sitting on my sofa no no trying
to like you know justifies this you know
it shouldn't have been set up but
everybody knew he had to be sent off so
but he never held it against he would
always still be the gentleman he was so
he wasn't a problem I tell you what used
to happen as well was in the man united
days where um and it was certainly a
coaching technique from Mr Alex Ferguson
was
and when he referred United they would
just keep coming at you one by one to
try and get the next decision push you
push you push in you know Rio Ferdinand
was a master of it he would come in then
Gary Neville would come in and Nikki
butt would come in Roy Keane would come
in they were just systematically come at
you never the one same player yeah it
was just one after another and the one
they were just influenced in the next
distance like the Tactical foul and it's
the sort of tactical approach when you
get experienced when you're a young
referee you're thinking how can I deal
with this and then when you get a bit
more experience you're just laughing
here tell your coach I know what you're
doing and talking to coaches uh was
there any managers that you sort of
collectively pulis yeah
there's some good I suppose when when
the coaching
that 90 minutes that can be a disaster
you know awesome Banger was a prime
example of that when arsenal were
winning and they were Invincible awesome
thing I was one of the most gentlemen
I've ever come across always
acknowledged always appreciate my style
of referring because I I knew how
Arsenal would play and I knew teams
would want to foul Arsenal because I
want to stop them because they're quick
but I used to try and find little
advantages so to open the other team up
and they knew I could do it so they
scored some goals because I I could see
the next movement and they could score
so he liked my style of refereeing but
near the end he got bitter you know over
you know he wasn't he didn't have that
control and dominance that he used to
have and therefore he gets frustrated
and then I used to get his frustration
even though half of it most of it wasn't
my fault so
but that was just a 90 minutes outside
of it completely different Tony pulis
was another example you know he's
passionate you know when he was at Stoke
for example my mama mia you know one of
the most difficult stadiums to referee
because it's so cold even in the summer
but in the way Tony pulis used to play
his teams you know it was always high
balls long balls in the box and you know
and he would always attack you for 90
minutes but afterwards complete
gentleman so you saw that in football
the emotions of it because at the end of
the day they wanna they want to win
football matches and you want to do your
best you can without being controversial
and try and get as many calls right you
know what I thought was interesting
there mark you said that there was a
moment when you were coming out for a
second half and Vincent company put his
arm around you because you were
agonizing over a decision that you
previously made in the first half
how do you
how do you deal with decisions like that
because obviously you can't let it
impact what you do in the second half
you can't let it be an equalizer or
anything like that no how do you try and
put it out of your mind yeah two wrongs
don't make a right yeah however
you've got to understand football you've
got to understand everybody wants
balance everybody wants fairness so what
do you do to one team you fed to the
other team I think that's what most
people like accept and when you've made
a mistake when you're a young referee
it's harder to deal with because you're
frustrated and you're like I've made a
mistake and what I used to do
psychological and we used to have a
psychologist to help you I used to just
concentrate on the first half of the
game I never used to think about the
second half I used to put everything
into the first half get a half time
analyzing my head I haven't made a
mistake and that used to make us feel
like Superman going out to the second
off thing and I've not made a mistake in
the first half I'm going to make sure
that I don't make a mistake and the
worst thing is for a referee is the last
few minutes because you can have the
best game
but in 89 minutes you make one decision
oh yeah and you sometimes the ref you
think don't go in the panel area duck
the ball don't go in the pedal area
don't go in the pedal area because that
was always the key moment yeah penalty
yeah or no penalty there that you know
when it was in Midfield you're thinking
oh good kid and you talk about um having
a psychologist and you know that sort of
mental side of the game did you ever
struggle with you know outside let's say
there was a bad decision would you ever
struggle with that or and how was your
coping mechanisms did you have something
you'd go to to help not for a podcast
because we're in the right environment
um it's difficult
I had a good family so for example they
would just disappear when I got home
they would disappear the new by me voice
I would be traveling home she didn't
have to read the the news or the social
media the Twitter she knew by me voice
that I was frustrated with myself most
of the time I was because I was a
perfectionist I wanted to I wanted to be
perfect and unfortunate in refereeing
and football you can't be perfect
players aren't perfect referee's on
perfect coaches on in fact nobody is
perfect but you want Perfection and uh
you know I used to really be in a bad
mood if the game was a sad I was really
bad mood Sunday I didn't want to do
anything I wouldn't go out
and
then on a Monday you started
re-revaluating because then you got
another match on a Monday night
for the weekend again so you had to
refocus so you just had this revolving
circle of trying to deal with the
emotions and I suppose the hardest bit
is when and it probably players might
say the same as sometimes as refs you
are making one or two mistakes or one or
two decisions that were controversial
and it seemed to happen one after the
other and you're like just give me one
quiet match what do you think this is it
and then something else happens like how
is this it feels like the world's
against you and then there's other times
you you just and you're probably put
more into the game you're probably
running faster you're probably running
more and it's still something's
happening and then other times
you just relaxing and then nothing
happens and you're like how is this do
you think that closure would have helped
in terms of maybe if you had to face the
Press maybe if you had to explain a
decision it would allow that to be over
yeah with closure for VR is a good one
because when I was in China I used to
use vrcm in Saudi so what was good
especially to clear your mind you've
made a call
thinking oh God I would look
I want to say that at the end of the
game we don't need to because if they
are saying it go to the screen you've
got the second chance to see it which is
a which is a great thing because then it
means I can move on yeah even if you've
made a mistake at least you can correct
it do you think ref should have to
explain decisions do you think there
should be a bit of press time for Rift
yeah I think we'll see in the next six
months that or even in the next month
that referees will explain their
decisions over VAR I think there'll be a
microphone soon and I think fans in the
stadium TV companies will hear the audio
because it's transparency why should you
not hear what's going on with the ER so
I don't agree with the post match I'm
not in I'm not interested in referees
speaking after the game I don't think it
has its much you know coaches now and
the players now are just they're like
recording you know they're seeing the
same thing yeah it's just another day so
there will want referees to really do
that I don't think it adds any value but
I think what we'll add value is what we
hear the referees miked up and also the
vrs Mike dubs we can hear the
conversations do you think that's a good
idea because I remember they they tried
this once didn't they I think it was
David Ellery in a millwall versus
Arsenal game I know this is decades ago
this is sort of Tony Adams Paul
mercenario yeah
but it wasn't really transmittable what
we were hearing yeah is that is that a
worry
and empty as it was but I think the
games changed so much now I think you
know the language is completely you know
I'm not saying it's completely removed
but it's changing all the time the
society is changing so much so what you
hear on the field isn't isn't as bad as
it used to be
but
even when what you can do and that was
done deliberately because it was for the
TV companies when you've got the uh you
can't hear what the place
see it's only what the conversation yeah
if I speak when we when we used to
listen to to audios from the referees we
couldn't hardly hear the players even if
they were five meters away because of
the the way the system was built but
certainly with technology with the VR if
you're for example you're you're you're
sitting at home or you're in the stadium
and you're thinking well why why is the
VAR
interfered then if you could hear that
conversation
I think people would accept it more and
probably embrace the technology more
because sometimes the technology or the
the use of the technology is called and
you're not really understanding the
procedure what's gone on
why the VR didn't interfere here and I
think we've had them dialogues I think
it would be beneficial and yeah what
relationship do you have with other
referees is it like a Brotherhood type
kind of thing do you all stick together
in the tough and good times we used to
have Christmas parties
what was the best Christmas films
you're okay
what I found referees are very strange
I'm probably strange people probably
haven't
I think we're a strange bunch in there
you know it's it's interesting when you
leave when you leave it's even more
strange nobody contact you every
referee's used to say that a lot of
referees used to leave the group
as a premier league referee and you
never hear from people again you know it
just seems to be the life it is you know
there's a lot of rivalry in the group
because everybody wants to be games some
referees didn't want the big games
because it was scared but you know in
general most of the referees wanted big
games and then with that you had the
Rivalry when you went into UEFA matches
because everybody wanted to be you know
doing the top games abroad so who was
your rival do you have like a an arch
nemesis we used to work I used to work
with Howard web a lot I work with them
in the euro in 2012 in Portland in
Ukraine I was his additional behind the
goal and
supported him so I didn't have that I
didn't want rivalry I just wanted to
help people I wanted people to help me
you know I don't see anybody as me rival
I'll try me best if me best isn't good
enough and somebody's better than me
that's life but I'll try and be the best
I can and then when Howard was retired
at the Rivalry with Martin Atkinson and
you know he went to the euro I went to
the euro
um he did the Europa League final I did
following you I did the Champions League
final so it wasn't what I liked about
the Rivalry some people used to see it
as a negative but actually
of the last 10 12 years even though
people think English reference in a bad
state
you know that we've done an awful lot
with referee two Champions League finals
uh Nations League final Anthony Taylor
under 17s under 20s Olympics Games final
Euro final the Europa Europa League
final Europe final World Cup so actually
English rephrase yeah don't Nelly I've
done every final so credit to English
referees so everybody thinks it's a
negative one well it's a positive one do
you think do you think that is because
the Premier League is so well coveted do
you think just by default oh no
disrespect but do you think it's by
default that the referees get better
opportunities than let's say other
countries or do you think it is the
referees I think it works in Cycles
because for example
how would Webb was lucky in 2010 because
English clubs weren't so dominant
the national team wasn't so dominant
right then we had a period where in for
example I think was it 28 nine English
teams dominated Champions League
then you had an era where they didn't
and they went through a cycle Spanish
Italy teams became so their referees
couldn't do finals and then all of a
sudden we had a chance and then I had a
very lucky
point because in 2016 Man City played
Real Madrid in the semi-final of Man
City win oh you're not doing it I can't
do the finals so I was lucky in that
period that the Spanish teams were
strong yeah now the English referees
haven't got so many opportunities
because English teams will be strong in
Champions League so it's Cycles do you
think that this is a quality that's
needed to be a good referee
a sort of arrogance quality
I wouldn't say arrogance confidence but
people say too much confidence can mean
arrogance people used to say that about
meow but not only you that maybe Graham
pole my Dean but I don't think it's com
it's arrogance players never used to
call us arrogant but the fans used to
maybe the way I acted maybe the way I
ran maybe the way I looked all of this
people are prejudging you all the time
that's just life now whatever you do in
life people are pre-judging everybody's
got an opinion
um but at the end of the day this is a
fine line between arrogance and
confidence I was probably
shy
but probably I looked arrogant but I
wanted to be confident and I wasn't all
the time you know you want to show the
players that you're confident because if
you show your confidence players used to
leave you alone so you had to make sure
that you didn't look arrogant I know
that's very hard to explain but you know
there is there's a fine line but for me
the most important thing is a ref is you
know man management skills I remember
doing a game when I was in Grassroots
and I sent the player off and he was
going to wait for us to to attack us
after the match and it was the only time
I ever got a match free after the game
because I ran straight at my car after
the final whistle and that's wrong but
it was a survival not to get me match
for you just to get out of the out of
the area because I didn't want to be
abused I didn't want to be attacked
I remember going out on nights out with
me friends and there was players in the
bar and players in the toilet and saying
are you a ship referee and you know I
hope you're not referring me on Sunday
and stuff like that so you've got all of
this but what it does it creates here
man management skills survival skills so
when you go on the field when you go on
the field
as a ref especially in your early part
it's about survival and the ones that
are the most successful are the ones
that have the man management
and um I know this is a bit a bit out of
what we've just been talking about but
of course Mike Dean always pops up as
being a bit of a cult hero now and I
know obviously like you'll see him
online these videos come out when he's
like hey big family fan obviously
um would you first of all would you
consider him a celebrity and then
secondly would you say that you set
yourself out of them to out of YouTube
Sorry who's the biggest celeb I don't
even want to celebrities it's you no I
think
is it what he's done he's he's had the
same Journey as Meek and I think from a
Sausage Factory to become a Referee so
he hasn't really come from a you know a
normal a normal industry or a normal
industry for refereeing for example
policemen School teachers that type of
environment what I liked about Mike din
was his personality I like referees with
personality and he had such a
personality he was always laughing and
joke and when we used to meet up every
two weeks he wasn't the funniest guy
because I mean for example we me and
Phil that was the Joker we used to hide
things mess about
um so we had we had that but Mike Dean
was always sharp funny popular within
the group a good referee referee top
matches so he was well respected and you
know I think I was half expecting them
this year to probably appear on Strictly
Come Dancing I'm a celebrity
but he stayed on as a VAR so probably
limited his options and now probably
next year people forget who Mike Dean is
so but over me and him probably probably
him
I just all I wanted to do was do the
best I could as a ref and I tried to do
that whatever happened outside of it I
just want to look after my family so
you've spoken to us about your agent
um you've already done a sideman charity
game is there going to be a hat-trick
are we going to see you we'll sing on
Strictly or maybe in a jungle I think
it's me age and would want the
commission from it but you know if I had
the opportunity I'm sure that he would
be pushing that to me I'm not showing me
wait for the letters I think she's seen
as dancing and I am the worst dancer in
the world I'm a celebrant like would you
go in in the jungle and eat some
I'm probably the only person I don't
understand
but now they I think there's no way I
could eat that no I'd probably want to
be voted out plus the problem I've got
is because I'm probably one of the most
hated probably men would be in there
because they're probably voters just to
upset us so not that I really fancy that
but I always wanted to um do the
voiceover for Big Brother like dear 45
in the big brother
2016. take you back there good year for
you yeah yeah you were I don't think
this is Extreme to say you were the best
referee in the world then yeah yeah it
was hard it wasn't 2016 that was it
started before that probably 14 13 14
and I'll tell you a quick story what
what happened was
you set goals at the start of the season
and that was 50 yeah yeah maybe in 15.
and we set goals
and one of me girls was to referee
semi-final of a Champions League you
don't set your goals to I'm going to
referee the World Cup final championship
final because sometimes things aren't in
your control but my plan was to do a
semi-final
and I was appointed
I was appointed the game I knew I was
going to get the game and how you win
used used to know we didn't have the
appointment but we used to get the
flights so we just opened the flights
and when I'm flying to Munich it didn't
take a genius to work out I'm gonna
referee Bayern Munich
so I'm referring Bayern Munich Barcelona
so this is second leg and to do a second
leg it's privileged because the second
leg is one of the most important
so I watched the first leg and I watched
it six times I'm analyzing it I want to
make sure that I'm ready for the game
because it's one of the most important
games in my life and I watch the game I
turned up with the game like it turns up
the match day before
Colleen has me observe and I'm like oh
no way it could be a Luigi cleaner me
bosses me observing me much so the next
day over the uh over lunch he said I
want to see I want to speak to you so
you opened his laptop he said have you
watched the match the night before the
game before I said 100 I have I've
analyzed it six times he said have you
really answered yeah he says did he say
anything in the game I said no no
so you're sure no no no he's sure
there's six clips if players tactics and
all it was was Thiago from Bayern Munich
who was at Liverpool now the smallest
player just blocking
um PK from Barcelona who's the tallest
player and if you remember the Barcelona
team at that era they were all small
players so they were just creating mola
lewandowsky spaces to score you know and
I'm thinking wow this is incredible
level of detail
and that was the moment and I just sold
it on the pitch I gave a free kick after
30 minutes I said to Tiago if you keep
doing that my friend I'll punish you
with a free kick nobody even knew in the
stadium but the players knew the coaches
knew and the players after that I could
give six penalties and the players
believe this because they realized I was
at their level they knew what out they
were doing and that was quick piano
Luigi cleaner helped us his he analyzed
the game different to anybody else and
he learned me to do that so I was going
into players heads
before they actually did it and the
players were like how you know that
because I know you're going to do it and
when you got into that level of detail
players were just so scared and realized
you're actually one of the top referees
because you they knew you knew our
tactics normally referees used to blow
the whistle penalty and react yeah top
referees don't reactor actually yeah you
see it before so all of these details
helped me
to reach 2016 and I was then best
prepared for all of the finals yeah
people I made mistakes I made a mistake
in the Cup Final band FA Cup Final not
playing an advantage to Palace I
probably made mistakes in the Champions
League final somebody will tell us
I probably made final mistakes in the
Euro final were human beings I didn't
have the AR then but what I did and
people don't appreciate
the for them three finals the only thing
I really wanted to do and it's sad is to
blow the final whistle because then you
wanted to get off that pitch without any
controversy starting the match is
nervous because you have 90 minutes in
front of you and you just don't want to
be remembered for any mistakes yeah and
talking now there's three big big cup
finals
um what was the what's the process of
finding out that you're going to be
referring one of these funnels do they
send you a letter that's in the email
like how does the process find it work
so the ethical finding somebody from the
the referee Committee of the football
association in London contacted my
mobile saying that you've got the you're
going to referee the FA Cup Final the
channeling one was a bit strange more
stranger because I'm traveling down the
M1 to go to the meeting to the referees
it's uh St George's Park
and Pier Luigi's cleaner my mobile goes
Luigi
and at that point I'm just about to pass
an exit for the motorway so I quickly
pull off the exit because I couldn't I
didn't want to speak on when I'm driving
and I pulled over and I'm thinking to
myself no Pierre Luigi's ringing is he's
gonna you've done something wrong yeah
you're always ready I've done something
wrong something what have I done what
have I done I'm Wrecking me Burns and
then answer the phone call and he said
how's things I said ah very good he says
congratulations finally on the FA Cup
Final I said appreciate it thank you
very much
he said um would you like to go to Milan
and I knew Milan was a championship fan
and I said
and why I said what I said was that all
of the media
around the world was saying Jonas
Erickson from Sweden would referee the
final because Jonas was very experienced
great friend of mine he would be
refereeing the finals so my reaction to
Pier Luigi cleaner was great I would
love to be fourth official
and he said who said you're going to be
fourth official
I said sorry he said
who said you're going to be for the
[__] I said what do you mean he said
you're going to be refereeing I went
don't like me typical Jordan accent
don't be stupid he didn't understand it
because he's Italian and I said sorry I
I shouldn't be doing the game and he
went do you not want the match and I
said course I won the match of course I
won the match so we ended the phone call
and I Rings my wife
and I said classes we're going to Milan
she went what do you mean I'm going to
referee the championship and she went
you know what the first word she said
can I buy a new handbag
so I thought well that was a nice phone
call so I started ringing me colleagues
because I had a team steady team and Jay
Colin cried Simon Beck was like
everybody was in shock but I couldn't
tell Andre Mariner because problem with
Andre Maroney was closed he had he was
going on holiday so when I got to St
George's I took him privately and I said
to him look
um are you unavailable on these days he
said biasis because I'm referring the
championship fan I would like you to
come it's me additional behind the goal
he said I'm going to close my holiday
I'm going the Champions League final so
we're going to announce I think was five
o'clock in England on Sky Sports it was
it was an amazing feeling I'm in my
bedroom
and five o'clock there was Mark Clement
is going to be has been appointed the
championship fan I'm like wow and I mean
mobile phone just goes crazy so you have
that moment and then the Euro was
different because you're in a tournament
and it's we had been in a tournament
because at the end you want to go home
you've been there a month so it's yeah
it's an anti-climax I know that sounds
bizarre but it feels an anti-climax
because you've been you start the
pre-tournament with all the education
programs and then you start refereeing
so I I refereed I think my first game
was Belgium Italy second game was Czech
Republic and uh Croatia
and then I'm going to do Swiss Poland in
the first knockout so you have nice you
haven't had nice games no controversy in
the games and then you get tall look if
england don't qualify
that you have a chance of the the final
so I'm dancing up and down in the bar
like I said before I'm the only
Englishman happy
and then I remember going to the fan
Zone the next night I said to me guys
look let's enjoy one night let's have a
couple of beers let's go and enjoy one
night so we went the fan Zone in Paris
to watch Belgium Wales and it was the
more surreal thing I've ever had the
most down I've ever felt because nobody
expected Wales to beat Belgium
and Wales would have affected my chance
I've been in the Euro because Wales were
a part of England so nobody expected
Wales to qualify for the semi-final and
I'm like when they beat Belgium I left
the fans on in bits because me dream of
doing the Euro final one chance now
hinges
I knew the hotel rooms would be
difficult to book me I looked on books
surely that's no no no yeah you were
suddenly having to get on TripAdvisor
oh yeah that's ridiculous and it booked
me on flight I had to book me white
slides booked the hall to tell for me
why I'm more expensive hotel no no I
look for a hotel so I didn't get the
final I could get me money back hahaha
I can't believe you I can't believe that
I thought that when the when they're
like organizing tournament for the
Champions League it was completely
different you ever sold everything right
for the Euro it was completely different
because it's a tournament it's not a
one-off game I know it sounds like
you're doing the final so it's my
responsibility you got tickets I think
I've got many tickets for the final but
I had to bring the I flew me wave over
and then she she watched the game you
should all Revolt you rest you should
all come together that's appalling
there's too many strikes going on
Erickson as well as being one of the top
referees at the time what do you think
he was the best referee old would you
say you were above him at the time
no I used to look up to him he was a
good friend of mine very very talented
referee I never used to think I'm better
than anybody else because you know what
you're only as good as your last match
everybody could say oh Mark was good
today I can guarantee next week Mark
Clement's the worst referee in the world
it's just the way life is you know so
you've got to take that all I did was I
tried me my hardest I was training every
day I lost for example when I first
started in the premiere I was 93 kilo in
the end I was 74.
and I look like a football player
because I was training I was running I
was fitted in the players and when I had
that much desire because I wanted to be
the best not in the world I just wanted
to be the best I wanted to give me
family something to be proud of that
look all of this effort in the end
there's a reward you know how many hours
a day were you training roughly ah three
two three hours but it was ridiculous I
used to get wrong for it I used to do
high intensity sessions three four times
a week wow and like I would referee
again and I was telling a story before I
remember a refereeing West Ham
next day I run the great North run and
then two days late I'm in Madrid
refereeing at Real Madrid yes too much
yeah
I remember one story remember one story
was hilarious and that was when I was
fit I remember cassia's got the ball
Real Madrid through the ball right I'm
running a full Pelt I think I just got
past the halfway line and all of a
sudden the big chair went up Ronaldo
scored I thought
yeah the ball's coming back
that's amazing do you remember all of
those games in full you know those um
Cup finals do you remember them can you
no no there's what you end up doing is
watching them back I've never watched
the Euro final back I don't know why I
couldn't get a copy Champions League I
watched couldn't get a copy YouTube me
not because you know what my daughter no
no no no no no that's a true story you
know the problem was right a Sky Plus
did
but you know what my daughter did
decided that she wanted to overrule it
for bloody Peppa Pigs or something
like that happens and it's family life
isn't it so I could have got a copy and
you know sometimes
the memories I didn't I was frustrated
after that match of the Euro final I
would have thought like you know they'd
send you a nice little package like that
with a DVD you know like a little uh I
don't know Memento from the game just to
you know really you only ever got DVDs
when you've had bad performances right I
probably should have gone
all the club used to slay the DVD and
watch that because you've had a
nightmare
nothing
new career though is probably the
Champions League final if you were to
say one event the Champions League final
has to be like the jewel in the crown
doesn't it yeah yeah because it's the
biggest Club game in the world isn't it
so in the referee the two Madrid sites
yeah you know I'm used to refereeing
Premier League I knew all the players
okay I knew the a lot of the players but
you need luck and people don't
understand this look
you know it's all about skill skills 90
biology used to say to me there's no
such thing as look courses look yeah
because I'm refereeing Athletico Madrid
and I think I referred them twice before
the final If That season and one of them
was against PSV and it's nil nil going
and it has to go to penalties in the win
I think 14-12 or something ridiculous so
the win and they're happy with my
performance and then I go to referee
them in a semi-fan which never happened
before ever your referee is semi-final
real Athletico Madrid against Bayern
Munich Guardiola was a coach of buying
Atletico win one nil no controversy
nothing in the match from a referee ah
come off certainly guys thank you very
much for the season we've had a great
season let's enjoy the euro and then
you're getting a phone call to do the
final that never happened before because
normally yeah circumstance isn't it yeah
but normally they wouldn't let your
referee one demon from the semi because
the other team will complain but Real
Madrid were happy that I was refereeing
because Real Madrid had always had good
matches with me I never caused any
problems so from a balanced point of
view the clubs wanted me to referee the
game amazing and you've got a Memento of
the occasion the Champions League yeah I
have the match ball no yeah
what made you go for a tattoo because I
know there's a lot of different things
you could have done potentially to what
why a tattoo what was strange was nobody
knew I had the Olympic Games because I
referred the Olympic Games in 2012 their
final Brazil Mexico so I got that first
done I thought I'll get the Rings why
not
um some Memento of my first achievement
in in football and it was funny because
everybody I used to have to wear long
sleeved after that because I used to try
and cover it up so nobody could see it
and as I was wearing long sleeve that
was 45 degrees
and somebody said to me are you ever
going to wear a short sleeve and I'm
like I can't I always wearing long
sleeves so and then I thought after the
2016 I thought I'm going to get some
memories and what it did and people will
say you know you shouldn't get tattoos
and and that's it everybody else don't
tell me what to do I don't tell you what
to do that's fact I can do whatever I
want as long as it's legal I'll do
whatever I want so I got these tattoos
and what it did when you're having down
dares are you having down moments I used
to just look and go you know what you
did achieve something in life so when
you're having really down moments which
everybody does it just gives us that
little bit of you know thinking wow I
did really do that you know and pinch
myself because sometimes you know I
didn't realize that I would ever reach
the highest level I did so so there's an
Olympic ring status to commemorate the
moment in 2012. you've got the 2016
Champions League final you've got a
Champions League trophy yeah anything
else we need to know about the Euro the
Euro I should have got the uh what was
it that charity matched on shouldn't
that yeah
[Laughter]
you know what
you know it's a chance to you know the
worst thing you could ever do with
tattoos is get a girl's name yeah
yeah so they are forever like they if
you're gonna get tattooed with anything
that is an achievement that will last
eternity and you know people will always
be negative about it but for me I say
there's a positive that you know I
started off in life
you know
difficult difficult life bullied at
school and then you come through and you
realize that people can achieve
something in life and that's the most
important thing for me it doesn't matter
who you are where you are what you come
from if you work hard you can achieve
amazing mark thank you so much for
coming on we really do appreciate it
this has been fantastic I've really
loved this episode thank you so much for
joining us hold on I thought you said
Tony pulises was better yeah
everybody thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
we'll start with the fact that ganabri
was at Arsenal for four years so he's an
Arsenal player he had arsene Wenger
there as his manager four years and then
they longed him out and they loaned him
out because they couldn't get anything
out of him if he was doing well he just
stayed at Arsenal but they couldn't get
nothing out of him so he came to us